we begin this morning with more
heartache along the hurricane battered
gulf coast
heavy rain and strong winds are again
pounding coastal louisiana and portions
of texas and mississippi
after hurricane delta became the 10th
named storm to hit the u.s mainland this
year
it crashed to shore near the town of
creole louisiana about 15 miles from
where laura struck
land six weeks ago killing more than two
dozen people
this time the streets have been turned
into rivers at least 600
000 people are without power as
relentless
powerful winds knocked down lines and
wires
delta was downgraded to a tropical storm
overnight but the dangers it carries are
far from over
as it moves slowly inland winds with
winds of about 45 miles per hour
maria villarreal begins our coverage in
hard hit
lake charles louisiana maria good
morning
good morning you know the wind and the
rain were intense for several hours
overnight but the good thing is the
storm blew through here pretty quickly
now these piles right here they were
here after hurricane laura hit lake
charles
but what is new this morning is there's
a lot of debris now scattered onto the
roadways
we also know after speaking with the
cajun navy they made
several rescues overnight and that's
because there was some major flooding
that started to build up
and is now on a lot of the roadways here
in this area
hurricane delta blew through making
landfall friday night as a category two
storm
drenching the gulf coast with torrents
of rain
fish in the road the storm surge is
coming in and the fish are
swimming up the road delta's winds
topped out at 100 miles per hour
knocking out electricity to hundreds of
thousands of people
many of them still reeling after
hurricane laura that hit just six weeks
ago
that storm followed nearly the same path
as delta
and left nearly every building and home
in lake charles louisiana damaged
it's hitting like probably 15 miles from
where it hit originally so we're really
worried about
how our house is doing right now this
morning 2500 members of louisiana's
national guard
are fanning out to help in hard-hit
areas i want folks to be hopeful
because we know that we're going to do
everything that we can to get them
right side up again delta is the fourth
named storm to hit the state this year
oh the need is enormous it is absolutely
enormous if you've driven around and i
know you have
you just see fences down blue tarps
on every roof some unfortunate us we've
already gotten our house roofed
but it's just devastating darren
worthington is a minister in lake
charles
his church coordinates relief efforts
and while he's confident the city can
bounce back
he admits this string of storms has been
tough
when did you start to feel that anxiety
i
actually said it's 20 20. what else
you know it just was one of those things
it's just been that kind of year
our live shot is actually powered by
generators so that's why you can
actually see the light even though we
are in the dark right now the thing
about the city is most of the
electricity is out
everywhere not just here but all the
surrounding areas as well it could be
days if not weeks before it
is fixed we also know right now there's
a lot going on with the city people will
start to assess the damage as the sun
rises over the next hour
and try and figure out what really is
salvageable after two unprecedented
hurricanes
hit this exact area jeff maria thank you
very much